ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
ministre de tutelle d'atout france
organisme en charge de la promotion de
la destination touristique france à
l'étranger
il semble en effet qu'une note interne
au quai d'orsay envisage un plan
d'économies drastique
atout france entraînant un plan social
de grande ampleur ayant pour conséquence
de réduire d'un tiers la masse salariale
également d'économiser près de 4
millions d'euros
l'opérateur business france d'ailleurs
seraient aussi concernés alors
évidemment nous ne sommes pas contre 2
nécessaires économies dans l' usage des
deniers publics bien au contraire
mais convenez monsieur le ministre que
cette coupe claire entraînerait la
fermeture de plusieurs bureaux à
l'étranger
quel impact aurait grandement les
missions de rayonnement d'attractivité
des destinations françaises dont atout
france a la charge
alors que notre pays subit depuis
plusieurs semaines une dégradation de
son image auprès des touristes étrangers
en raison des mouvements sociaux de
grande ampleur que nous subissons
ma question est simple monsieur le
ministre quelles sont vos ambitions pour
la promotion du tourisme auprès des
clientèles étrangères
la parole est à monsieur marc fesneau
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice d'humains
le tourisme est un secteur clé pour
notre économie en même temps qu'un
instrument d' influence majeure à
l'étranger c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement fait du développement
touristique de l'ensemble des
destinations françaises l'une de ses
priorités
les objectifs que nous nous sommes fixés
en terme de fréquentation et de
retombées économiques qui sur les
prochaines années sont ambitieux à ce
titre les résultats de 2018 sont à cet
égard encourageants avec près de 90
millions de touristes étrangers mais
nous devons encore faire davantage et
atout france est au coeur évidemment de
cette stratégie vous évoquer la question
des moyens
les grandes orientations données par le
gouvernement dans le cadre d'actions
publiques 2022 impliqueront
nécessairement et c'est logique une
transformation de la présence
internationale de l'état de ces
opérateurs
et donc d'atout france en évaluant
l'efficacité de l'action de chacun nous
aurons donc très rapidement rapidement à
mener une réflexion stratégique sur la
manière meilleure manière pardon
d'utiliser la promotion d'assurer la
promotion touristique de nos
destinations à l'étranger avec atout
france et ses partenaires publics et
privés
mais en ce qui concerne plus
particulièrement le financement de la
promotion touristique
le gouvernement s'est clairement engagé
lors du conseil interministériel du
tourisme du 19 janvier dernier deal 2018
pardon en apportant des ressources
supplémentaires pérennes notamment par
le biais de la recette visa le ministre
jean yves le drian et le secrétaire
d'état jean baptiste lemoyne resteront
mobilisés pour que les collectivités les
professionnels et l'état rassemble leur
énergie et leurs moyens en faveur de la
promotion des destinations dans un
modèle partenarial qui caractérise notre
politique touristique et qu'incarne
atout france le gouvernement a également
conforté atout france dans sa mission
d'appui à la structuration de nos offres
touristiques
c'est le sens de la mise en place du
dispositif france tourisme a généré
porté par atout france et la banque des
territoires qui accompagne les
collectivités locales dans la
structuration de projets touristiques
d'envergure à même de répondre à une
demande mondiale toujours plus exigeante
c'est en effet en agissant à la fois sur
la demande et sur l'offre que nous
pourrons atteindre nos objectifs de
fréquentation et de recettes
touristiques et à faire mais plus encore
la vocation touristique de notre pays et
permettent que ce secteur soit l'un des
vecteurs de la croissance et de l'emploi
je vous remercie madame dumas pour
quarante deux secondes
oui monsieur le ministre on j'ai bien
entendu votre réponse vous ré affirmer
votre ambition pour l'évolution du
tourisme dans notre pays je m'en réjouis
mais justement vous parlez du conseil
interministériel du tourisme j'en suis
membre
et c'est justement à cet effet que je
vous redis qu'un vaste plan social
atout france serait un paradoxe au
regard de l'objectif en quantité en
qualité que le gouvernement a fixé
également un paradoxe
aussi au regard de la concurrence de
plus en plus vives
d'autres destinations en europe et dans
le reste du monde